thank you to brilliant for sponsoring
this video
the world is changed
i feel it in the water
i feel it in the
i earth it in the air
once that once was is lost
for none now live
who smell it
two terms that are used almost
interchangeably are climate change and
global warming while there is a
technical distinction between the two
i'd argue that fundamentally global
warming is abstract while climate change
is experienced the entire planet warming
by one or two degrees is abstract
wildfires raging in your country for
several weeks longer per year is
experienced more frequent and more
extreme heat waves are experienced
living far from the equator and becoming
more likely to catch tropical diseases
is experienced but experiences also
include the more mundane things like
food and drink tasting different or
becoming more scarce for example coffee
is likely to be more difficult to grow
in a warmer climate meaning it'll be
more expensive but another mundane
experience that's likely to change is
smell the world will smell different in
the future to us and to other species
and the world's actually already started
to see some sense go missing and we can
expect many more to go extinct in the
coming years but smells go extinct all
the time for example some technical
smells like telephone books and polaroid
film and also social smells like smoky
beer-soaked pubs are all but extinct at
least here in the uk and we can in fact
preserve scents for future generations
in a kind of smell archive more on that
later so smells disappearing from nature
in itself isn't something that should
concern future generations but
what happens after those smells go
missing
is another matter entirely for example
the ocean now smells different not
perceptibly to us but very much so to
certain marine species this is because
smells are fundamentally chemicals that
are absorbed by our sensory organs and
interpreted by our brains in the
atmosphere those chemicals are
transported by air mostly oxygen and
nitrogen from their source to our nose
in the ocean of course those chemicals
are instead transported by water however
ocean water has gradually been becoming
more acidic due to increased carbon
dioxide concentrations in the atmosphere
dissolving into it and forming carbonic
acid on a molecular level this means
that there are more h plus ions floating
around than there were before and the
extra electric charge in those h plus
ions can change the shape of a scent
molecule when it's suspended in water
and how animals detect those scent
molecules is highly dependent on their
shape so the same molecule in a slightly
different shape could be misinterpreted
or entirely missed by sensory organs one
specific example of this that
researchers have identified is in shore
crabs female shore crabs carry eggs on
them and ventilate them by wafting water
over the eggs knowing when to do this
based on the kind of smell that the eggs
give off but in more acidic waters the
female crabs aren't able to smell their
eggs as well meaning they're not capable
of ventilating the eggs as effectively
and so the number of viable offspring
that each crab will on average produce
decreases but more generally if a smell
like say the smell of food or of a
predator is less detectable to marine
life forms then that makes their lives
much more difficult add to that the fact
that more acidic water results in at
least some fish producing fewer smell
receptors and causes organisms to
struggle to form hard shells in fact
their shells may even start to dissolve
in the water if it becomes particularly
acidic there is the very real
possibility that ocean biodiversity will
collapse as a result of this climate
change driven ocean acidification all it
would take would be a few species to go
extinct due to these sensory pressures
and the ripples would be felt throughout
the ecosystem there very likely would be
a cascade of species ceasing to exist
and the ocean's going quiet but that's
just a situation in the sea caused by
water becoming more acidic here on land
we face a different problem
flowering plants
are starting to smell less
this is for a couple of reasons firstly
air pollution such as ozone and nitrous
oxides from car exhausts are reacting
with scent molecules in the air before
they reach our noses meaning that the
average distance ascent molecule can
travel is reduced so we can't smell
flowers from further away but more
importantly neither can pollinators like
bees secondly at least some species of
flowers produce fewer aroma-producing
compounds when grown in higher
temperatures than those grown at normal
temperatures so the plants are just
smelling less and thirdly some plants
emit different scents if they are
stressed a classic example is the smell
of freshly mowned grass that smell is
actually a defense mechanism by the
grass plant warning other nearby grass
plants that they might be damaged soon
and also stimulating new growth in the
damaged plant but stress isn't always
mechanical and a lack of water or the
temperature being too high can alter the
scent given off by a plant all of these
reasons together produce a world that
smells different and smells less as i
already said that's hugely troubling for
pollinating species in particular and
hence for the reproduction of plants and
the outlook for this century doesn't
look good forty percent of all plant
species are at risk of extinction due to
climate change and other human
interference and forty six percent of
all flowering plants are if we don't do
something about this
soon the world will smell very different
to our children and to their children
and a fundamental building block of the
global ecosystem will have been removed
and just like with the oceans that will
have a cascading effect on other species
you simply can't survive if the
flowering plant that you feed on doesn't
exist anymore and neither can the
species that are symbiotic with you or
the species that predate on you as i
mentioned earlier though it is possible
to archive smells and these techniques
have actually been used to bring a smell
back from the dead of several extinct
flower species basically you take a
sample of a smell and look at the
molecules that are present in that
sample separating them out and then
using mass spectroscopy to identify
which compounds make up that smell and
in what relative concentration so to
recreate the smell you just put together
a mix of those compounds in their
correct relative proportions it's a bit
like learning how to make a salad by
buying one and disassembling it into its
component pants and counting how many
lettuce leaves and tomatoes and cucumber
slices go into a salad but there are
problems with this for example how do
you choose which smells get preserved if
you only have finite storage space and a
finite amount of time to do the
procedure then you're going to have to
pick certain smells as being worthy of
being remembered
and who gets to decide if it was up to
me i'd probably pick a smell like say an
english woodland in summer but that's
going to mean nothing to somebody from
south america for example but more
importantly while preserving smells is
great and all it does nothing to
preserve the biodiversity that will be
lost in those smells absence in the
natural world so while we could preserve
smells for future generations and i
think there's an argument that we should
we'd be better off stopping those smells
from disappearing in the first place and
addressing the root cause
climate change climate change is a
many-headed hydra impacting so many
parts of our shared existence on this
planet the experiences of weather of
smell of food of wildlife and it will
take a range of strategies to defeat
but fundamentally it's very simple
keep the carbon in the ground
don't put it in the air instead let's
keep that air filled with the smell of
flowers and forests and a world rich
in nature to quote a certain hobbit
it's worth fighting for
i'll be honest i was never particularly
good at chemistry i never really clicked
with the subject and now that i'm more
than a few years out of school there are
many opportunities for me to improve my
knowledge beyond just learning cool
facts on the internet enter brilliant
brilliant is an educational website and
app that offers a variety of expertly
written courses on subjects in science
maths and computer science including an
introductory course to chemistry if
you'd like to learn more about how acids
like carbonic acid introduce h plus ions
into a mix then this is a great place to
learn crucially blind isn't about
learning cool facts it's about learning
the processes that underpin chemistry
and neural networks and electricity and
so many other subjects it's about
getting your hands dirty and answering
problems and emphasizing that if you get
an answer wrong that's more than okay
because you learn from the experience
brilliant is all about learning by doing
to me this is what education is all
about and i'm so happy that brilliant
have become a long-term sponsor of this
channel in the time that we've worked
together they've massively improved the
interactivity of their problems and
they've added dozens of new subjects
brilliant is a perfect resource for
adults who want to improve their
understanding of science and maths but
also for students who want to supplement
their learning in the classroom if you'd
like to get 20 off a year of stem
learning in your browser or on your
phone then head to brilliant.org simon
clark and get your hands dirty solving
some problems thank you again to
brilliant for sponsoring this video
thank you for watching the video i
realized that this one was really rather
depressing sorry but i think it's
important to talk about these topics
because it shows how pervasive climate
change is and how it will affect
everyday existence
so if you did enjoy the video please do
pop it a like and if you want some
recommended viewing here's some up here
that just leaves me to say thank you for
watching i'll see you in the next one